this has been one of my most requested
shows to cover and apologies on not
getting to episodes one and two so I've
decided to do what I like to call a mini
breakdown basically a breakdown which
covers all the theories Clues and
Mysteries without all the recap filler
I've left timestamps below so you can
see all the topics I'll be covering
let's not waste any time because Knight
is fast approaching perhaps the biggest
new mystery revealed thus far is the
mysterious chained man named Martin
there's not much we know about him other
than he's been chained here for several
years and has a U.S Marines tattoo is it
just a coincidence that his name means
god of war in Latin like Boyd this man
has traveled through the far away trees
but seems to have a lot more experience
added stating that the monsters are but
the tip of the spear when it comes to
the evils out there could whatever this
new malevolent entity be the same person
or persons who contacted Jim on the
radio at the end of season 1. Martin
also also knows about Boyd's wife and
how she believed all this was some sort
of dream somehow a man chained up knows
about what happened in town so either he
has some sort of connection to what's
going on or someone is feeding him this
information when Boyd makes it back to
town and talks to his son about his
journey I found it quite interesting
that he doesn't even mention Martin at
all I mean you'd think he'd talk about
the emaciated chained up guy in a
medieval dungeon but this withholding of
information likely has more to do with
Boyd hiding his new Affliction while
trying to help Martin Escape Martin
slashes at Boyd stating my blood is your
blood now almost as if he's passing on
some sort of bloodborne disease we saw
Martin with these almost worm-like
creatures in his skin and later on we'll
see Boyd with them as well while little
is known about this Affliction there are
two interesting things that happened to
Boyd after he contracts whatever these
things are number one it seems to make
him invisible to the monsters while
traveling through the forest at night a
group of them just walk right past him
number two is Kelly's reaction to Boyd
when he arrives she starts screaming in
pain when prior to his arrival she was
calm and this could be completely
coincidental but in the season one
finale there was a whole monologue about
worms and whether they know where they
are Boyd even makes a weird statement
that if you cut a worm in half it grows
back into two worms Kelly and O'Brien
happen to be two Travelers aboard the
bus that arrives in town at the end of
season one they fled into the forest
after being scared Away by Donna but are
caught by two of the monsters we
actually never find out what happened to
Brian for all we know he could still be
alive in some form or another but it's
implied he was killed in the sadistic
torture act for Kelly to watch Boyd also
finds it odd that this couple Kelly and
Brian have the same names as the first
person he ever killed a soldier by the
name of Brian Cal who was in
excruciating pain after his truck was
hit by an IED in Iraq and just a
reminder if you like these types of
videos please be sure to like And
subscribe and leave your own thoughts
and theories in the comments below while
ransacking Victor's room Jade steals a
violin something that seems to hold
sentimental value to Victor with Victor
mentioning his love for his mother I
wonder if this something his mom used to
play while recovering in the hospital
Jim notices that the electricity has
come back making the exit sign flicker
above the doorway a few scenes earlier
his wife told him that the wire she was
tracking below their house LED nowhere
so how can this light be on if there's
no power and just as he's about to
inspect it fanny pack lady interrupts
something is super odd about her the
first time we see her in episode 1 she's
dancing in the rain we learned that she
was on her way to bet money at the
racetrack so she strikes me as someone
very lonely and with nothing to lose we
also see her coming into the infirmary
leading me to believe she has some sort
of illness maybe that's why she was
dancing in the rain enjoying what
remaining time she has left when Jim
asked her what's in the fanny pack she
refuses to answer maybe it's medication
while being shown around town by Fatima
newcomer Elgin asked if there's any
water nearby remember in episode 1 that
he had some sort of seizure and was said
to experience a vision in his dreams it
seems his vision had this Pond the
interesting thing I found about this
scene is Fatima stating that no one has
been able to find out why they're stuck
here which instantly leads me to believe
that Elgin will be the key to finding
that out throughout the episode Tabitha
sees these two dead children one of
which seems to be this same child found
in the tunnels as far as we know only
Tabitha can see them and they are
different than the monsters as they are
seen in daylight they have these burnt
clothes and hair suggesting they died in
a fire and Tabitha tells Julie that the
feeling she got from them was not
peaceful Tabitha finds Ethan playing
with what he calls a puzzle this Cairn
looking structure looks similar to the
one found in the tunnels where the
ghoulish child was found Cairns usually
serve one of two purposes to act as a
marker or burial ground Ethan also
mentions that this quote-unquote puzzle
belonged to someone before him maybe
this was a game or puzzle that belonged
to these two children finally we have
the reappearance of Sarah who last we
saw guiding Boyd into a Faraway tree
saying she would be right behind him at
the end of season 1. did she go into
that tree with Boyd at all or did she
end up somewhere else like that
Lighthouse they saw obviously Boyd will
have a lot of questions for her I'm
curious if we'll get an episode which
flashes back and show us what happened
to Sarah during this time anyway that's
it for this quick Theory breakdown if
you want to see more of these types of
videos please be sure to like subscribe
share and leave your own thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember these people are foxy
sure